Let's go to the phones, which are exploding
today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 0 40 750.
And see what's on people's minds starting
today with our caller from the 4:43 area code,
caller from 4:43.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
This is Anthony calling from Maryland.
All right, Anthony, we've got you.
Sounds like you have gremlins in your phone.
But go ahead.
Ben SHAPIRO resonated video titled Fascism
is secretly a left wing ideology.
He said that fascism means he said that left
wing means more government and right wing
means less government.
So that fascism is left wing by that definition
and anarchism is right wing.
Would you agree with that sort of that description
of the political compass?
No, I wouldn't.
More versus less government is very different
than saying more or less a libertarian, for
example.
What matters is what government is doing.
What matters is how is government interacting
with people and government doing things is
not fascism.
But Anthony, I'm going to let you go because
your connection is it's so bad.
It's just a very, very strange noise that's
there.
And hopefully it's not another one of those
embarrassing instances where the problem is
on our end.
We'll find out with our next caller.
Let's go to our caller from the 7 0 7 area
code caller from 7 0 7.
What's your name and where you're calling
from?
Hi, David, this is Bart, and I'm calling from
San Francisco.
Hey, Bart, what's going on?
Your connection is pristine.
I must say.
Oh, I'm a Brit.
I'm glad.
Yes.
Question for you is, did you figure out your
YouTube issues with the algorithm?
I know you were having issues with that and
I emailed you awhile back about that.
I was just wondering if you know what the
status was of that.
Well, I don't I don't know which element of
that you're referring to, because the YouTube
algorithm is sort of like a lobster regularly
shedding and molting and having a new shell.
And it's a constant new series of issues.
But certainly so YouTube has whitelisted us
for Corona virus monetization.
So that issue has been solved.
But there's always issues.
You know, we we there's search issues, there's
other issues.
So I don't know exactly which issue you're
referring to.
Right now, the biggest issue is he was the
man.
It was the monetization.
Sorry, it was the money's there.
And I was just there.
There are people like me out there, tech people
out there.
I think that can help you.
But just in case you're interested.
You know, there's people in it can follow
you.
I think could be helpful.
Okay.
Well, we you know, we are always any tips
and advice are welcome.
But right now, I mean, the big thing now is
because of the virus and fewer advertisers
wanting to advertise CPM is or how much you
make for every thousand views are down about
30, 35 percent.
That's not right.
That's more of a stomach issue than an algorithmic
issue, unfortunately.
Gotcha.
Then one of the other callers, this question
is what can we do to help?
Never.
Biden folks you mentioned that are saying
never Biden and so on.
And who are the leaders of that movement?
How can we help convince them to go down a
better road deal these get through this transition
point.
The leaders question is an interesting one.
I don't know who leads the Never Biden movement.
That's a I mean, it's again, I think that
in the same way that support for Bernie was
overstated.
If you just looked at Twitter and read it
the size of the never Biden movement, maybe
overstated if you're paying too much attention
to Twitter and read it.
I think it's a smaller movement than than
maybe people on the Internet think.
But I don't know that there are necessarily
leaders to convince.
I'm not sure.
I don't know if there are.
I mean, like, are there prominent?
Never Biden people.
I'm asking genuinely.
I don't know.
I don't I don't know, I just listen to your
comments about that and how how there you
are mentioning that there's a movement.
I was just trying to figure out ways that
we could help convince that movement and where
to go on Twitter or wherever, you know, to
talk to people and to help to help them.
Yeah.
Listen, traditionally, what's been the only
thing that's been at all effective?
And there there are probably more effective
things is to really drill down on.
OK, so who do you want picking the next Supreme
Court justice?
Whose policy do you prefer on the environment?
Whose policy do you prefer on taxes?
And usually with most of that, I mean, listen,
if they actually prefer Trump's policies,
than they should be voting for Trump.
And there's not much to argue about.
But usually people will realize, oh, I prefer
Biden's policy on everything.
Why would I do anything that helps Trump get
reelected?
It's counter counter intuitive doesn't make
sense.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
Absolutely.
Last question.
Why can't reporters do real time debating
with with him?
So what's the what's the real issue?
Is it just access?
And what's your take on that?
And how do we convince them to be a little
more forthcoming?
Yet just silences them.
He moves on.
He controls the bully pulpit.
And it's hard to insist on a debate with Trump
in the press briefings, although I also wonder
what the outcome would be.
I think it would just turn one lie into four
that now you're trying to fight.
So we've talked about before.
I don't know.
Thanks, Bart.
Really appreciate the phone call.
Hope to hear from you again.